someone's Nick's over there this is how
the cage fighters of Swindon prepare for
battle over the next few hours they'll
be punching kicking and grappling
complete strangers but first an
unexpected question you know you're
voting the referendums I know probably
40 out so you could have not shown to us
to be honest you're not bothered no you
gonna vote probably yeah we'll see what
what are you what are you guys saying
about the referendum then I'm definitely
gonna vote and anybody that doesn't
should be ashamed of themselves really
why yes really yeah it's if you don't
really know that what we voted on there
were those what's going on that what we
voting oh but you very well said we
don't know anyway they're either in a
specialist dead process i understands
nothing is where you like where you work
or toast or position or something you
see I feel like even if you've got the
right to make this isn't happy for you
stan is this so guys VIPs aside but what
does swindon's fight fans think of the
referendum campaign so far 14 months now
passionate politicians have been at each
other's throats as it made them more
interested in the referendum as it put
them off and has it swayed their vote EU
as long as it don't affect me I don't
you you don't think it will effective
know why not hey I'm not smart enough to
know by it slowly though are you gonna
do huh why not what
I'm not really interested in to be
honest do you not think it affects young
people we let yourself it probably does
but we're more interested in having a
good time and enjoying life forever than
worrying about the future really so it
doesn't doesn't worry you all the doom
and gloom that they're saying might
happen ready I found here tonight not a
lot of people are saying they're
bothered or leg in a vote it's probably
because I don't wanna talk about it
tonight also I think there's a lucky we
don't care no absolutely not people
don't aren't even bother they don't know
they're not folks to know whether to
stay in that's what is clearly the
political drama of this referendum is
failing to get punters pulses racing but
what about the staff the ones who stay
professional and sober no matter how a
fight goes how long have you been ring
girls for I've done nearly every rage
contest for one so you've been in a
while yeah I'm actually here talking
about the European referendum okay what
are you thinking about it do you know if
you're going to vote in Iraq or too much
you care I'm voting in why's that
because it's not be made
how many of trade deals of where is too
dangerous I think I think it's not a
good time to do it I'm not saying in the
long term it's a bad idea but I don't
think now is a great idea because David
Cameron I'm not particular fan and I
think it'd just be left in the hands of
him and it'd be a dangerous situation to
end up what are you thinking my music
exactly the same exactly with just days
to go the campaigns are bound to get
more aggressive and there are clearly
still many votes to play for before the
contest is over Joe tidy sky news in
Swindon